hi yes thank you
and welcome to automate out yourself out
of a job with roslyn which is the first
tech talk i've done in two years in
front of people um i've been happily
sitting at home at my desk with my like
four or five monitors and my big
powerful pc and
so yeah it's been a while and i am a
little bit terrified so i'm sorry
um
my name is mark rendall and i am a net
developer
i've been using net and c-sharp since
the first beta of net back in late 2000
i'm a microsoft mvp
which doesn't matter at all but
apparently when you're speaking you have
to go i'm a microsoft mvp
it's the only reason i do the speaking
is so that i get to be a microsoft mvp
and get free software and
and stuff
um
but my job i work on something called
visual recode which i'll talk about more
later on
but let's start off by talking about
what roslin actually is
so
the first sort of few versions of
c-sharp and the first few versions of
net the c-sharp compiler and the vb.net
compiler were written in c plus and then
around the time of between c sharp five
and c sharp six there was a huge project
to rewrite the compiler for c sharp in c
sharp and to re rewrite the compiler for
vb.net in vb.net which serves them right
um
any vb.net programmers in the room
because i'm
sorry yeah
um
not for what i'm saying i'm just
sorry
um
and when they rewrote the compiler for
c-sharp in c-sharp they didn't just make
a new compiler they built it
uh
they decided to make a compiler as a
service so they built it in an open way
so that all the developers in the world
who were doing c-sharp work could hook
into the compiler and use bits of the
compiler tool chain to work with their
own c sharp code and so essentially we
all became c-sharp compiler developers
because we've got access to these parts
of the c-sharp compiler and and it's
completely awesome um fundamentally the
thing it's most often used for is
writing analyzers
which either install into visual studio
or you can reference them as a nuget
package in your project and then it adds
the squiggles under lines and if you're
really lucky it adds the fix for that as
well and we'll take a look at that later
on
but i got into using roslyn basically
because microsoft canceled wcf
which was a good move
wcf needed to be cancelled wcf was uh
started in 2006
and it was basically a way to get net to
do soap
and soap
really belongs in 2006. i mean it
doesn't belong anywhere but if it's
going to be anywhere at all 2006 is a
nice safe place for it and let's just
leave it there i know java people still
love it but but no
um
and a lot of people were very upset by
this and microsoft said the the thing we
suggest that you migrate to is grpc
which is the new sort of rpc hotness um
it's created by google although the g
does not stand for google nobody knows
what it does stand for it just doesn't
stand for google
and
so there are a bunch of people in the
world who've got um tens of millions of
lines of code all wrapped up behind wcf
service contracts and operation
contracts and data contracts and i
thought i wonder if you could just use
roslyn to scan over all those service
contracts and data contracts and
generate the protobuf file uh that would
be the equivalent grpc service and so i
started hacking around with that and it
turned out yes yes you can and it's um
i i want to say it's surprisingly easy
but i also want people to buy my thing
so um
it's it's kind yeah um and i actually
ended up going not only can i do that
but i can also generate the code
so that we can bring across your old
service contract and then just put a
grpc proxy in front of it and so i dug
really really deep into roslyn and all
that sort of stuff and so that's
how i got to know about it and why i
want to share it with you because you
can use it for for things like that you
could
put together your own visual recode and
avoid buying a 125 license
but you can also use it to sort of scan
over a c-sharp object and generate the
equivalent typescript object or
interface or class or whatever
or lots of things
so
to get started with roslyn
it's essentially just a bunch of new get
packages
and they've just with c-sharp 10 they've
gone to 4.0 on the new get packages and
so this is what the project file would
look like
we have
microsoft.codeanalysis.csharp.workspaces
and that brings in
microsoft.codeanalysis.csharp and a
bunch of other things and that contains
all the types and classes and and
libraries that you need
to start analyzing and passing and
understanding and working with c sharp
code in your code
we also bring in
microsoft.codanalysis.workspaces.ms
build and
that is the thing that hooks the roslin
compiler up to a version of ms build
that is installed somewhere on your
machine and that could be the visual
studio version of ms build which is
closed source and scary as hell or it
could be the net version of ms build
that's hiding under program files dot
net slash sdk somewhere
and that lets you work with
net core and net5 and net 6 and all the
latest versions of c sharp
and then up at the top there we have
something called microsoft.build.locator
which we'll talk about more in a minute
so at the root of everything that you do
with roslyn is workspaces or r
workspaces
workspaces um they're like above the
solution and you can think of a
workspace as like a virtual instance of
visual studio that's running in memory
and that's taking care of all the things
around the solution and so roslyn
workspaces
you have three different kinds you have
an ad hoc workspace which is one that
you can just create and then add a
solution to it and then add projects to
the solution and add documents to the
projects
and that's really helpful for unit
testing and for hacking around and
exploring uh roslyn and getting to know
it
and then you have the ms build workspace
which is the useful one that actually
hooks in with the ms build process and
gives you useful information about the
the types and the code that you're
working with
and then you have the visual studio
workspace if you install the visual
studio extensions
option when you're installing visual
studio
then when you're writing an extension
you know the vsix thing you can get the
current
top level workspace from visual studio
and work with it inside your code
and below the workspace we have a single
solution
which you can load and
from a solution file or you can create
in memory if you're using an ad hoc
workspace and a solution contains
multiple projects
and
those will be c-sharp projects or vb
projects but they can also be service
fabric projects or
random kinds of of
all the different projects that you can
have in visual studio basically and then
projects contain documents and again
some of those documents are c-sharp
documents and some of them are
not
uh so we start out by locating a copy of
ms build and this is what ms build
locator is for and so i hope this code
is big enough
i i
was so terrified of this first talk in
ages
that i sat last night in my hotel room
and i ran through the demos and just
screen grabbed them rather than trying
to live code in front of you guys so i
apologize if you love the thrill of live
coding it's not going to happen
but the first thing you do in any roslin
project that's running from the command
line so not in a visual studio extension
but if you're building a console
application to do something funky is you
run this ms build locator dot register
defaults
and if you're running a net 6 console
application it will go off and it will
find the
net 6 version of ms build if you're
running a net framework 4.8 application
it will go and find the full.net
framework version of ms build and then
everything that you do after that will
work with that version of ms build
super handy
it has to be
or it doesn't have to be the first thing
you call in your application but it's a
hell of a good place to put it because
if you call anything else ms build
related before you've called ms build
at register defaults it'll just randomly
choose an ms build environment based on
alphabetical order or the position of
the sun or something and you won't know
what the hell's going on
so then we create an ms build workspace
and we can load a
solution into it and we add an event
handler to
workspace.workspace failed so that if
there are any compiler errors or
problems loading that solution
you will get them
printed out there and you can see
why things are not working
there is
a problem with this which i found out
the very very hard way if you use the
net core version of roslyn
and you try to load a full.net framework
solution into it it will not work
because the ms build that is used for
the full.net framework has a whole bunch
of targets files and those targets files
reference a whole bunch of full.net
framework dlls which don't work in net
core and so uh you will just you'll
it'll look like it's working but then
you'll find out that actually half the
projects are showing as having no
documents at all and you can't find the
things that you're looking for and those
three months that you spent refactoring
the engine of your visual reco tool to
run externally as a grpc process because
you thought that would be good because
visual studio is only 32-bit doesn't
actually work and you have to put it all
back into visual studio and then
microsoft released visual studio 2022
and that adds anyway that's my problem
visual studio 2022 is at least 64-bit so
my terrible code is no longer going to
cause out-of-memory exceptions as long
as you've got 128 gigs of ram installed
in your pc
and why would you try to run visual
studio if you don't
okay so we've got our our solution and
all our projects loaded into memory so
what's the basic unit of code of c sharp
code when we want to work with that in
roslin well we start off with syntax
trees
so the way the compiler works and the
way most compilers work these days is
you throw a load of text at it and it
tokenizes it and works out which bits
of the
text are individual components and those
can be keywords or open braces or
comments or attributes or method names
or identifiers or whatever
and it turns that into a syntax tree
and syntax trees
we have at the top level we have a
syntax tree and then we have a syntax
node so the tree is a collection of
nodes and every single tiny smallest
possible unit of code becomes a node in
that syntax tree
and we have syntax tokens so a keyword
is a syntax token an identifier is a
syntax token
an open brace is a syntax token
and we also have syntax trivia and this
is all the stuff in your code that is
not actually code so comments are trivia
and white space is trivia and
all of these things are contained in
this syntax tree
and if you have installed visual studio
sdk you get a really handy thing built
into visual studio that helps you
understand this syntax tree which is
called the syntax visualizer and you can
go to
view
other and about two two-thirds of the
way down
there is a syntax visualizer no
one-third of the way down
uh there is a syntax visualizer option
and then you can dock that to the right
side of your document well
and as you click around your code in the
other side you can see
where that is in the syntax tree and
this is a fantastic way when you're
first starting with roslyn and you want
to understand how syntax trees work just
load a little bit of code up nice simple
bit of code and then just click around
it and watch what's happening in the
syntax tree on the other side and you
can see the node that you've got
currently selected and then down the
bottom there's a nice property view that
shows you all the properties that that
node has
so that lets you get to grips with how
the syntax tree works in your head and
and the concepts behind it
so then you want to start navigating
that syntax in your code and there are
two ways of doing this two primary ways
of doing this and the first one and the
simplest one for most c-sharp developers
is to use link
because in the same way as we have link
to xml
and you can say
elements.elements.elements.elements and
and do a nested query down into your
your xml document you can use link and
do these queries down into your syntax
tree
and so that looks like this
so we've got our solution loaded which
came from our workspace and we passed
that into our
little demo function here and we say for
each
var document in
solution.projects.selectmanypd.document
so we get all the documents in the
entire solution
and then we say
get the syntax route for this document
so that gets us the root node of the
syntax tree for that document if it's
not a c-sharp document then that will
come back as null so we can just ignore
it and that could be sort of an
appsettings.json file or any of the
things that are included in the project
and then we can go into root.descendant
nodes so there's a root.child nodes
which is just the first level of nodes
below the root root.descendant nodes is
essentially an eye enumerable of every
single node in that entire document and
so we can go through that and we can say
we want to look for base type
declaration syntax so every
node
has a type that ends with syntax
and a class declaration or an interface
declaration or an enum declaration or a
struct or a record now in c sharp
9 and 10
will
be some type so classes class
declaration syntax interfaces interface
declaration syntax i'll leave you to
imagine what the rest of them might be
but they all inherit from base type
declaration syntax so we can grab that
out there and then that type declaration
syntax node has an identifier property
which says this is what this thing is
called and we can use that we can get
the text property out of there
we can get the namespace
by
so the namespace declaration syntax if
we do first and ancestor or self we can
move back up the syntax tree looking for
the first node type that matches that
and so that will be the namespace that
contains the class declaration and then
we can put those two together and just
write them out to the console and that
will look like this
this is like seriously meta demo here
because i'm running the application
against itself and so it's kind of
enumerating through its own code and
printing it out to the console line
so
that works quite nicely
um but you can end up with some
extremely complicated link code and you
can end up doing some nasty things that
are not necessarily particularly
performant and that becomes important
later on when you're trying to write an
analyzer because essentially your
analyzer visual studio is going to try
and run it
every time the user presses a key or
every time the user types a character
into their document
so that's not necessarily the best way
to traverse your code
and so we also have syntax walker
and
just to be absolutely clear here there
is a third type called syntax visitor
which
is like syntax walker and it's easy to
get them mixed up but the difference is
and and it's important to remember this
syntax walker is good and syntax visitor
is absolutely [ __ ] useless
don't use it
so with a syntax walker you inherit
from the
syntax c-sharp syntax walker based class
and then for every type of syntax node
it has a virtual on-visit
or visit method that you can override so
if i want to find class declarations i
can override visit class declaration if
i want to find interface declarations
and method declarations and parameters
and everything in your
code there is an override method in
there for it the really nice thing is
with intellisense you can just type
override and then spend a happy 15
minutes scrolling up and down the
intellisense and going oh yes you can
visit those
and so this gives us a very efficient
way of walking across the entire uh
syntax tree uh using basically the
visitor pattern but it's it's it's not
don't use c-sharps in tax visitor
because it only goes one level and then
you don't get the things that you're
expecting so you want c sharp syntax
walker although that is an
implementation of the visitor pattern
visitor is a bad implement anyway
so yes so this is another way of doing
this and then to use this these two
screens are in the wrong order
we just create a new instance of that
list types walker and then we go through
the documents and for each document we
do get syntax root async and then we
just say walker.visit
and pass that syntax document in and it
will basically go through that in
roughly the same way you can also say
root.accept
and pass the walker in there as well
that will work too
i have no opinion on which one of those
is the best way to go
and so that
produces exactly the same output as the
previous
demo but is
technically it's a better way of of
working with the code it's a more
efficient and memory uh
friendly way of working with the code
but what we've got here
is just essentially the tokens
wrapped in a nice tree that makes it
easy to find them and navigate them and
visit them and do whatever we want to do
we don't actually know what any of them
mean
so we might find a token that says
string with a capital s
and we might think okay so that's going
to be system.string but not necessarily
you could be working for a company that
sells string
and so it has an object called string
that they use all over the place and so
if it's lowercase string the keyword
string then it's probably system.string
but if it's an uppercase s then it could
be the string that they sell and we
don't know and trying to work that out
so going back up and finding all the
using statements and seeing if you've
got using system in there and does that
then mean string but is there a using
string equals
string code.string string
you it becomes complicated fortunately
all of that is taken care of for us
because this is not just a c-sharp
passer this is the whole c-sharp
compiler and so we have something called
semantic models
and these are the thing that really
helps you to work with your code and
know what's going on
so we compile
our project so we can say await project
dot get compilation async and if the
project's already been compiled that
will just load stuff from the assembly
and if not it will compile it and then
load stuff from the assembly
and then we can get the model for that
compilation
from
we can get the model for the syntax tree
that we're working with from that
compilation so we've got the document
and we've got the syntax tree out of it
and we can say hey
give me more intelligence give me more
information about this syntax tree
and what we work with then is symbols
so for every one of those syntax types
class declaration syntax and
uh method declaration syntax all those
sorts of things there is an equivalent
symbol in the semantic model
and we can grab that
so for each of these documents we can
get the syntax tree and we can compile
the project
and then we can uh
go through and we can combine this with
our link queries so we can say for this
document get me all the type
declarations
and then we can pass that in to our
uh model and say give me the declared
symbol for this type declaration syntax
and that will give you an i named type
symbol which is
a lot more information so that'll tell
you uh
everything about that type and then you
that's got properties inside it so you
can enumerate through methods and
properties and fields and constructors
and everything about it and you can get
full type information namespace
qualified so you can see if something is
system.string or stringcompany.string
and and work through your code like that
and it makes it so so much easier so you
can see here that we're getting the i
named type symbol for our type
declaration syntax
and then we can go through that and we
can say symbol.getmembers
and give me the method symbols from this
type symbol and that will give you all
the methods public private internal and
everything else
and then we've got this method symbol
one of the properties on there is
implicitly declared
so the c-sharp compiler bless its little
heart will generate a whole bunch of
methods uh while it's compiling the code
so if you have a property with a getter
and a setter then the c-sharp compiler
will generate two methods for that
property to set the hidden field that
it's created for you
and so we can use method symbol that is
implicitly declared to throw away all
the stuff that's been generated by the
c-sharp compiler and this works with
async methods and various other weird
things that happen in c sharp as well
it's fascinating actually just to go
through the
the syntax tree or the the symbol in the
debugger and just explore all the
ethereal stuff that the c-sharp compiler
gets up to behind your back
so the output from that
um
we have
well the auto-generated extensions has
an is auto-generated method and it
begins with auto-generated comment
method and then we've got our
roslindemo.dependencydemo
and so we get a lot more information
this way
and we can actually reason about the
types that
we have in our solution
there is
a symbol visitor class which works a bit
like the c-sharp syntax walker class
except
uh i have i tried to use it when i was
first getting started with roslyn and i
found it
less than useful
so i don't tend to use it a lot but you
can you can create a symbol visitor
which looks like this and it works in
exactly the same way as the syntax
walker you pass a semantic model object
like an eye name type symbol or
something into it and it goes through
and it visits all the items below that
uh in the um in the symbol
but i tend to just go through the
properties and sort of get members of
type method symbol and that sort of
thing
but
so yeah we can see here we've got a
visit named type and then if we go into
that we can find all the named types
within our
symbol whatever that might be and if
it's the top level then it would be like
an i namespace symbol
and then within that we can revisit
using the same visitor
to find method symbols so this doesn't
traverse down the entire tree you
actually have to take control of it and
say okay when you find a name type then
go into it and visit it again looking
for method symbols
and
visit property
and visit method will print things out
to the console like this and so now we
can see
that none of the classes i have in this
demo have any properties which is
completely pointless
but uh yeah
so let's talk about doing something
useful with this
let's see if we can find all the types
that are used by all the code in our
project
so we can go in to our solution and we
can say go through each project and for
each project we're going to get the
compilation which is the in-memory
proper representation of of what
everything means and then we can go
through the documents
and we can check to see if the document
is auto-generated and this is actually
really important in modern
c-sharp
code as well because
as of c-sharp 8 or 9
and net core projects in particular
you might have noticed we don't have an
assembly info.cs file in our.net or net
core projects anymore because it's
auto-generated
from the cs proj file but it is hiding
there somewhere in your project and it
will be one of the documents that gets
enumerated when you go to
project.documents it's kind of
assemblyinfo.g.cs
and now we also have source generators
which are generating random code which
is also hiding in our documents tree
somewhere and we don't necessarily want
to be going through those
so i've got an extension method called
uh
is auto-generated which looks for a
comment at the top of the file
containing the words auto generated
or looks to see if the
document extension is dot g dot cs
if you have something that is generating
code and if you're into the idea of
source generators and you didn't go to
the talk that was in
here or room 5 yesterday
somebody did a very good talk about
source generators which would be great
to watch after this one
then
and if you came here thinking this was
going to be about source generators i
apologize
um
please feel free to to complain
um
but yes so
if it's not auto if it's auto generated
ignore it
otherwise get the syntax tree and then
get the root of that syntax tree uh
check just one more time to make sure
it's really not auto generated um
and then get the semantic model
and for each of the named type symbols
that we have in this syntax node which
we get here
we have name type so we go
node.descendant node.of type identifier
name syntax so that is a
a variable declaration or a property
declaration or something like that
and we also have expression syntax which
is going to be like a literal string or
three plus two or a plus b or any sort
of anything that's an expression and not
a statement
and from that
if you have an expression that is uh
you've got two integers and you uh
called a and b
then you have an expression a plus b
and the type of that expression is int
and so you can get that name type symbol
back out and say this is an integer
expression
and then we can return those back
and then we can do
uh this which shows us every type that
is used by any of those identifiers or
expressions in your entire project and
you could use this for example to go am
i using anything from system.link.xml
and if i'm not then i can remove the
reference to system.link.xml
from my project
but the fun bit comes when you start
rewriting code where you want to make
changes to code or you want to generate
a new version of code when you're going
through net 4 code and looking for
things that won't work in net 6 and
putting comments around it to say don't
do this or putting if deaths around it
or that sort of thing
and rerude in roslyn at first is
extremely challenging because there's a
feature
that's built into roslyn that was a
fundamental design goal right from the
start and that
is immutability
so
things in roslin are immutable syntax
nodes are immutable if you change them
it becomes a new syntax node and this
goes right the way through the whole
compiler project what things in roslyn
are immutable
everything
literally everything anything that you
change will create a new version of that
thing which you then have to say this is
now the actual version of this thing
that i want to use so the solution if
you change a syntax node in a document
somewhere you have created a new version
of the solution
right at the top level
god knows what this does to memory it it
horrifies me but there's everything in
here is immutable um
does anybody use
system.collections.immutable
the nougat package it's super handy
you've got immutable dictionaries and
immutable arrays and immutable lists and
immutable hash maps
and every list or array anywhere in
roslyn is going to be one of those
collection types that entire nuget
package was basically created by the
roslin team because they needed it for
their compiler
and so that makes it quite difficult if
you're just linking or visiting through
your nodes if you change something how
do you
make that flow back so that that becomes
the canonical version of the solution
and so we don't
work in that way when we're trying to
rewrite code we use the c-sharp syntax
rewriter
and this is just like the c-sharp syntax
walker
but where the c-sharp syntax walker all
the methods return void
in the c-sharp syntax rewriter all the
methods return
a syntax node
so you take a syntax node in and if you
want to change it
then you modify it and you return your
modified syntax node back out of the
method
if you don't want to change it you
return
the original node that you were passed
in or actually return base.visit literal
expression because you never know what's
going on in the base method might be
nothing always best to call it
and if you want to remove the syntax
node entirely if you just go no that's a
terrible syntax node i don't like it i
want it to go away then you can return
null and it will disappear forever
and if you do that accidentally and then
ship the code that does it you can make
people very very very very unhappy
i know
so this is how we do this from the top
level we go through our projects and we
get our compilation and then we go
through our
documents
and we get our syntax root and then we
create a string literal up shifter which
is the most useful utility uh class in
the entire world it will just go through
your entire c-sharp project
and it will find any literal strings you
have anywhere in the whole thing and it
will add to upper invariant at the end
of them
and then your application will become
shouty
i am thinking of releasing this as an
actual visual studio extension and just
calling it shouty
um and seeing how many people download
it and install it that could be fun i
only have one visual suit i've got
two visual studio extensions one is
visual recode
the other which sadly doesn't work
anymore
was just called no git
and all it did you know it's impossible
to turn off the git integration in
visual studio and all it did back in
visual studio 2015 was every time it got
turned on it turned off again
it was surprisingly popular
but anyway back to this
so we get the semantic model and then we
pass
we create a new string literal up
shifter so this is a syntax walker but
we want to have the information about
the uh that we want the semantic model
passed into it and so when you're
creating a c-sharp syntax walker or a
c-sharp syntax rewriter you get the
model and then you pass it in when you
create the rewriter or the visitor or
the walker
and then it can use it internally and
then you just say
create a new route by passing this route
into that syntax rewriter
and then when you get that back
uh there is a
is equivalent to method that will
compare two syntax trees
and work out if they are the same
because you might get the same syntax
tree back you might sort of think you've
made changes but actually you haven't
and so use this is equivalent to to say
are these basically the same code if
it's not
then we actually have to call solution
dot with document syntax root which will
update the solution update the project
and
and make the new solution the one that
includes those changes
and then at the end we have to say
if the new solution is not the same as
the solution that is in the current
workspace then we call workspace.try
apply changes and pass a new solution in
and this gets really fun
because
if some other code running on some other
thread at the same time has also made
changes to the solution which are
incompatible with yours this is
essentially like a git merge and you
could have conflicts and so when you
call workspace.try apply changes what
you should be doing is checking the
boolean result and if it's false that
means the changes you're trying to make
conflict with the changes that some
other bit of code has made somewhere and
what you need to do is go right back up
to the top and start again with the
current solution and hope that it
doesn't happen the second time through
three or four times around that loop is
usually enough depending on how many
extensions and how many analyzers you
have included in your project
so that would take this code here
and turn it into this code here
and and that's basically it that's
that's a syntax rewriter
i will put all this code up onto github
at the end of the talk so that you can
actually go and and find it and do
useful things with it
so that's fun and you can write code
that generates c sharp code and you can
write code that reads c sharp code and
then generates other things based on it
and you can do fun stuff with that if
you don't like doc fx then you could
write your own doc fx by going through
and finding the uh synth the doc
comments on all your members
but the point at which this becomes
really useful is with rosalind analyzers
which i mentioned at the start
so you might notice these days
if you use x unit
it comes with its own squiggles and it
tells you that if you've got a theory
and then you've got inline parameters
and the number of arguments you put in
the inline parameters doesn't match the
number of arguments in your test method
you'll get a squiggle that pops up under
the theory that says this isn't going to
work
and there's a whole bunch of stuff in
there and most microsoft projects
asp.net core comes with a bunch of
analyzers that help you asp.net core
properly entity framework core comes
with a bunch of analyzers that help you
do that properly
weirdly enough rosslyn comes with a
bunch of analyzers that pops up
squiggles and says you're doing roslyn
wrong we've used roslyn to work out that
you're doing roslyn wrong how meta would
you like this to get
so
the the really helpful thing with this
if you work in a company where you've
got some shared code you've got
something that you do a lot and you've
written a nice utility library to wrap
around it to help you work with that or
you've got a shared repository project
or whatever you can
write your own analyzers and include
them in the same nuget package
as a as a dependency
and then when people
download your library and try to use it
you can help them you can be there
looking over their shoulder and going oh
no that's that's not the right way to do
that
i was working at uh one of the large
banks
and
working in a wpf application
and we were trying to work out why the
hell it was so slow
and the answer turned out to be because
we wrote it in wpf obviously
um but we thought we should do what we
can to try and make it faster and so i
spent a lot of time instrumenting the
entire application so that we could see
how long various things that were
happening as windows were created was
and to do this
we
were one team and there were about 10
000 developers at this bank and about
two and a half thousand of them use
dotnet
and if you want to introduce a new
package like app metrics for example
into that ecosystem that's about six
months of meetings and filling out forms
and and putting a case together and
everything else if you want to bring in
something from system
something from microsoft that's no
problem at all and microsoft
as part of the.net core project created
this thing called
system.diagnostics.diagnostic source
which essentially let you track
activities and create events and
everything else and then you can just
read those out and write them to
wherever you want to write them to an
influx database or prometheus or
something like that
and so i introduced this idea of using
diagnostic source
so you work with that you create a
diagnostic listener and
when you call it you just write a string
to identify what your event was
and then an anonymous object which
contains effectively all the tags and
useful information and the name of the
window and the thread id and all that
sort of stuff that you might want
and the key thing here
is we have a wpf application and we're
trying to make it faster
and i want to add code
and so people are going that's going to
slow it down and so diagnostic source
has this thing where if you've attached
a listener to it then it will uh it will
do something but if you haven't attached
a listener to it then you can just
ignore it and so doing this is wrong
because every time this static void bar
gets called we're going to create a new
anonymous object and set a to 42.
we don't want to do that what we want to
do is check to see if the diagnostic
source is actually enabled if
something's listening to it and is
listening for the event we're about to
post
then we call diagnostic right
now this is a nightmare who uses
microsoft.extensions.logging
in their code
who every time you call underscore
logger dot log information prefixes that
with if logger dot is enabled log level
dot information
bad bad people bad
you should
if you look in the dot net core code if
you look in the asp.net core code they
do that actually.net six
people are so terrible at this that dot
net 6 now includes source generators so
you can create a log method and it will
generate that boilerplate code for you
and prevent allocations and prevent
logging from happening at all and
creating objects and doing all this sort
of stuff and so i wanted something like
that for this diagnostic source so that
when you said diagnostics dot write
something it would do the little
squiggle and say you should check to see
if this source is enabled
and ideally be able to add that bit of
code to say
if diagnostic source dot is enabled
so if you go into visual studio project
templates you will find one of them is
analyzer with
codefix.net standard these are the
rosalind based templates and analyzer
with codefix.net standard will create a
project that has your analyzer
and
um
a unit test project so you can test your
analyzer
and a vsix project so if you want to you
can package your analyzer up as a visual
studio extension and distribute it
through the marketplace or just email a
vsix to your friends
and an analyzer has two important
components one of them is the diagnostic
analyzer that's the thing that looks at
the code and returns something out to
say that's not right you've done it
wrong you're the worst programmer ever
you should have been a farmer
and the codefix provider which is the
thing that jumps in for you and goes
never mind farming's a dying industry
anyway let's see if we can help you get
this right
so this
is an analyzer
it has a crap load of boilerplate code
the thing i really like about it is that
the boilerplate code causes squiggles
so the boilerplate code for writing an
analyzer is triggering the analyzer
that's analyzing the boilerplate
like i say this gets really
um
recursive but no so we have a diagnostic
descriptor uh which says this is the uh
the description this is what this thing
is looking for um we've got some
localizable strings which i've collapsed
there because i don't localize my code
just speak english
and we have a list of supported
diagnostics so that we can tell
essentially the visual studio runtime or
the rider runtime or by the way pro tip
who uses visual studio code
who misses all the helpful sort of
things from resharper or visual studio
when you're editing c sharp code so if
you go into the settings
in the c-sharp extension settings in
visual studio code there is a check box
which is not checked by default that
says enable analyzers and if you turn
that on you get extract method and
initialize read-only field and all the
things that you have in visual studio
apparently the reason it's turned off is
because it uses a bit of memory
but we're developers we've got memory to
spare unless we work for a big
enterprise company who doesn't know why
we can't use the same spec of machine to
develop the software that other people
use to run the software
and and if that's you then i feel your
pain
then we get down to the bit that
actually does something useful we have
our analyze mode analyze node method and
in here we can look at the
node that we get from our analysis
context
and we can say
is this a diagnostic method diagnostic
source method invocation
is it uh calling right on a diagnostic
source and we're going to pass in our
semantic model which we're also getting
from the context there which is coming
from the current compilation of the
project
and then we can call another method that
says is this guarded is there an is
enabled check around it anywhere and if
it's not then we can return a diagnostic
that will then generate the handy green
or red squiggles
and we can
control that with this diagnostic
severity dot warning so if you do
diagnostic severity dot warning that's
green squiggles if you do diagnostic
severity error that's red squiggles
so our isguarded method
looks like this
we can
look at the expression and say
is that a
literal expression syntax so are we
calling um
is enabled on on the literal um
otherwise do we have a matching symbol
that has is enabled called on it
matching symbol exists can just look
back up the parents of our current
syntax node and see if any of them are
an if statement and if they are an if
statement
then is the expression inside that if
statement acting on our diagnostic
source
um symbol and if it is is it calling the
uh is enabled so we got this
is diagnostic source method invocation
is enabled
and if we don't find that anywhere
between our diagnostic source dot right
and the top of wherever we get to so
like the method declaration or property
declaration
then we're going to say
if we find it we say yes it's being
called otherwise we just return false
out of this
similar thing when we're looking with
literals going back up and we have to
match symbols and literals because the
in the node that we're looking at could
be either of those
and then
so that will generate the green
squiggles saying hey you're using
diagnostic source.right without any
enable check
so that's told the programmer that
they're a bad person and should rethink
their life choices
and then we have the codefix provider
and these are a little bit more
complicated to write
but essentially
we are going to
find
so we register our code fixes we say
these are the diagnostic source or the
diagnostic warnings it was a bad idea to
use this because i'm talking about
visual studio diagnostics on one hand
and then this diagnostic source on the
other hand i'll fix this for the next
time i do this talk
so yeah we basically say we have a code
fix for when you get that warning saying
diagnostic source should be guarded with
an is-enabled call and so we can
register our code fix here
and then we have this bit of code here
and it's quite dense
but i think this really highlights the
fact that rosalind
is incredibly powerful and enables you
to do some really quite clever things
with a fairly minimal amount of code and
without really having to know too much
about compilers and syntax trees and
everything else
because this is a method that fits on a
single screen at 1920 by 1080 with a
reasonable font size and this is enough
to wrap that diagnostic source dot right
with an if diagnostic source dot is
enabled
so we just say uh we've got our
expression
which is going to be our diagnostic
source dot right and we can just get the
leading trivia off it whatever that
might be which is probably white space
and then
into at the end of the white space we
can just add if diagnostic source dot is
enabled i'm going to step out here and
use the laser pointer to point out where
these things are happening
it's very precarious up here
um so yes
uh
so we've got is enabled here we're going
to pass a syntax factory so this is what
lets us generate c sharp code in our
code fix and so we're going to pass this
expression and we're just going to say
source dot is enabled so source is
whatever the identifier for our
diagnostic source instance was and so we
can just pass this and say source dot is
enabled and that will give us an
invocation expression syntax
and then we can replace
the argument list in that which will be
empty with a new argument list which
adds in the argument which was the first
thing passed to
um
our diagnostic source.right invocation
so in this case that would be bar
and then we can create a new if
statement and so this past expression
lets us turn a c-sharp string into a
c-sharp syntax node but syntax factory
also you can just say create an if
statement and the if keyword should be
this token uh syntax kind dot if keyword
and then we're going to add an open
paren token
because we need that and then we're
going to put our is enabled expression
inside that there and then we're going
to have our close paren token and add on
trailing trivia newline
and then we can indent the expression
underneath that
i don't know what that else does don't
worry about it and then we're going to
add back on whatever the leading trivia
was on this thing before we started
[ __ ] around with it which should give
us the same level of indentation as we
had before
then we can just go hey give us the
solution from the document that we're
looking at and give us the syntax root
from this document and then we can
replace the node that was our old
expression up here with our new if
statement and then we can do that same
thing again and say
the new solution is the original
solution with this change to our
document syntax and then return the new
solution back
so yeah there's a lot going on
and it's not the simplest thing in the
world
but
for what it's doing
and how easily that integrates with
visual studio and is able to provide
helpful
tweaks to your code as you're going
along
you can
you can see that it's uh it's quite a
powerful tool
that you can use
and you can use this like i say you can
ship analyzers with code fixes uh with
shared projects internally with stuff
with nuget packages that you publish on
your internal nuget package um server if
you have uh particular styles of coding
that you like to enforce um
then you can use this to enforce those
coding styles
you can say this is an error
and these analyzers will also be run
during the compilation process and they
will put their warnings and errors into
the compiler output and so if you want
to say
if you're one of those places where
they're not allowed to use the var
keyword
then you could write an analyzer that
looks for the var keyword and reports
that as an error and uh then
add things to source control so that you
can't check in code that won't compile
and it won't compile because you've got
an analyzer in there that says the var
key word isn't allowed because
um
why why don't people i never understand
why people don't like the var keyword
it's great but yeah
um
you'll also have a test project
generated it will be an ms test
test project
for for reasons um but it makes it very
easy to test that your analyzer is going
to work
uh and so you just have your your test
fixture which inherits from code fix
verifier which includes a bunch of
methods that are helpful to make sure
that your diagnostic is working
and so you can say verify c-sharp
diagnostic on
the test string there
and make sure that that
doesn't return any diagnostics if you've
got an empty string then you're
definitely not calling diagnostic
source.right so that's not going to show
any diagnostics
you can then pass in a method that does
take
that does call diagnostics or stop right
and you can check that the diagnostic is
triggered and so you can make sure that
your analyzer is working with the code
that is important to you and then you
can also check the
fix code is working by passing in the
code that should trigger the diagnostic
and the fix and then also the code that
is what it should look like after the
code fix has been run
this is super handy this is so much
easier because the other way of testing
this is to press f5 and have it launch a
new visual studio instance with that
analyzer switched on and then type code
inside it and make sure it triggers and
all this sort of stuff
and
another
it's a damn good thing i decided to do
this um let's run through all the demos
and screen grab them and just turn them
into slides because when i tried to run
this project last night it didn't
because it was written for visual studio
2019 and i've only got visual studio
2022
preview one installed on this laptop and
it just didn't work
but trust me
if i had visual studio 2019 i could demo
it right now and it would work
brilliantly
but you'll just have to take my word for
it
so
yes here we have this is what it should
look like and then we can just call
verify c-sharp fix which is a method
provided by that codefix verifier based
class that says yep after i apply the
diagnostic
code fix
this is what the new code looks like
so that's basically it um
and i've done that
i never get to the end of my talks with
two minutes to spare let just hang on
i'll think of a tangent to go off on for
five minutes um
so yeah no uh if you want to learn more
about this um the thing i found super
useful when i was starting out and
trying to understand why my c-sharp
syntax visitor wasn't doing what i
wanted it to do and that i should be
using c-sharp syntax walker instead
josh varti.com learn roslyn now was the
resource i used to get my head around
all of this sort of stuff also on github
there is a net analyzers organization
that has a whole bunch of refactorings
and code fix providers and analyzers
that you can use to crib from and copy
and paste from and i'm writing a song
about that
if you have a net4 application and
you're looking to migrate to.net core
then please take a look at
visualreco.com
it's it's
it's a work in progress but it will
currently take your wcf application and
turn it into a grpc application and
we're working on making it do useful
things with mvc and web api and and
other things as well
and that is basically it
um i hope that was useful i hope that's
given you some ideas that you can go off
and start hacking on and do fun stuff
with
later on today at seven o'clock in room
three i will be hosting some fun talks
ahead of the party which is just
speakers talking about things that they
wouldn't be allowed to talk about in an
actual talk
and then the band dylan beatty and the
line breakers will be on later and i'll
be [ __ ] singing because i got drunk
once and went yeah all right
um
so yeah come to that and last slot
tomorrow if you're still around at the
end of the conference not sure what room
it's in but i'm doing a completely
stupid talk about the worst programming
language ever which is lots of fun so if
your brain's melted by the end of the
conference then come along to that other
than that five seconds to go i've been
mark rendall thank you very much for
coming and i'll see you again cheers
bang on
bang on zero
you